il ya des moments difficiles et tout le
monde tout le monde passe par des
moments difficiles la question c'est
comment tu va le prendre si c'est une
étape ou une épreuve qui va te pousser
vers l'avant ou une épreuve qui va
pousser vers l'arrière
je suis parti jouer à torcy du
historique donc je voyais de moins en
moins aimés par en fait si on va dire
c'était une petite préparation pour pour
l'angleterre elle a 16 ans arrivé dans
une famille d'accueil
parlez vous pas parler la langue donc il
faut faute de brouiller google
traduction tout oublier le grand dire
assez vite pour lui d'avoir 16 ans on va
dire tu as 18 ans quoi tu deviens un
adulte assez tôt c'était une fierté déjà
pour moi manchester et ma tête c'est
l'un des plus grands clubs de l'histoire
du football allez là-bas découvrir aussi
une nouvelle culture et montrer mes
qualités veut faire voir est arrivée
jusqu'en à ces témoins que ça va se
montrer sur le terrain en fait c'était
ça on va dire le passeport était déjà
dans la famille de rien lâcher et
continuer de se battre vouloir gagner
toujours gagner et pas vouloir être
deuxième tout ça en fait ça ça va
grandir avec moi et j'ai jamais perdu ça
tu parle justement de la famille à un
point qui est importante à bord dans le
documentaire c'est par rapport à ton
père tu expliques justement que que tu
as voulu vivre avec lui ses derniers
instants à manchester est ce que tu peux
nous raconter
c'est moi comment tu arrives à conjuguer
à la fois football 7,7 difficultés
personnelles tragique comment tu comment
tu j'ai un peu tout ça
donc ça commence et où j'avais un jour
un fou je suis parti de londres je vais
à paris
parce que mon père il était parti à
l'hôpital pour il avait mal au ventre on
savait pas ce qu'il avait donc et des
jeux je parle le voir est en fait tu
vois qu'il est il a une douleur à trois
on apprend avec tous les résultats qu'il
a qu'il a un cancer du pancréas et qui
lui restait pas beaucoup de temps en
fait j'ai dit on va tout faire pour
le garder plus longtemps possible bien
sûr et on
va trouver le meilleur hôpital ou faire
les meilleurs cause pour qu'ils soient
prêts nous qu'on puisse le voir
il est ville est passée à manchester
pendant quelques mois j'ai pu j'ai pu
quand même être à ses côtés
voilà en même temps avec le foot c'était
c'était un boost comme jeudi en corse et
je n'ai pas pris comme une comme une
détresse mais plutôt comme une force qui
voit là je vais on est en europa league
en utiliser on va gagner leur palier que
gagner l'europa league pour mon père
j'étais on va dire assez préparé pour ça
on va tous
on va tous y passer c'est quelque chose
qui est
entre guillemets naturelles etc ont cela
de mes pas mais voilà il faut le prendre
du bon côté aussi donc on a fait les
causes et c'était vraiment préparé ce à
préparer sa fin
dans les meilleurs dans le meilleur
terme possible gagner la coupe du monde
c'est mon rêve comme je pense que comme
le rêve de mon père aussi il n'était pas
présent donc j'ai toujours une pensée
pour lui quand je gagne des trophées
parce que c'était le premier qui me
poussait à la être le meilleur vouloir
toujours gagner des trophées devenir
premier en fait donc ma pensée fera
toujours vers lui
dans ce port et dans la vie en général
c'est la tête qui contrôle quand tu es
bien dans ma tête les choses c'est plus
fluide et plus faciles même au havre des
moments où voilà je suis pas titulaire
je suis dit en fait tu pas bon il faut
que je travaille plus faites moi je lui
prenais comme ça il faut que je
travaille plus pas il faut que j'arrête
faut que je travaille plus fait y'a pas
de bar tu peux toujours monté en fait tu
peux toujours monter
je me dis toujours ça en fait
que même si j'ai rêvé je rêvais de jouer
en équipe de france j'ai les faits j'ai
joué une coupe du monde je les fais
gagner la coupe joue au marquée tout ça
a été fait donc il n'ya pas de limite en
fait il ya encore des rêves
des objectifs que je peux toujours
atteindre gagner la peinture comme celui
qui n'a pas été fait donc ça fait un
objectif gagner un championnat
anglais et gagner toujours des coupes en
fait toujours plus il ya un os sujet
aussi important je pense notamment pour
pour ceux qui nous suivent sur brut
c'est la lutte contre le racisme on sait
que c'est des choses qui arrivent
malheureusement encore trop souvent dans
les stades dont toi tu as déjà aussi été
victime
est ce que tu peux nous raconter un peu
avec un peu de recul ces événements là
sont des événements assez
on dira c'est triste c'est de
l'ignorance ou de la provocation ne sais
pas dans un stade de foot où tu viens
pour chercher vraiment pour voir un
spectacle pour les amoureux du football
en fait quand tu es fan du football tu
es obligé d'aimer les couleurs parce
qu'il y avait tellement de joueurs de
qualité dans différentes dans différents
pays et différentes cultures différentes
différentes couleurs quand tu es un fan
de foot tu es obligé d'aimer les
couleurs tu peux pas de baser sur une
couleur en fête et voir ça sur les
terrains c'est bien ça ne doit pas ça
doit pas y être on est là pour donner du
spectacle surtout aux supporters et vous
faire plaisir leur faire plaisir ils
viennent pour nous supporter à la base
supporter leur équipe et tu veux pas
voir ces actions-là caire et clarins
higelin moi c'est ma force là ça c'est
en fait c'est juste
être bon leur donne encore plus de
spectacle parce qu'à la fin et ils vont
pas pu le dire et ça a déjà été le cas
il faut être
plus radicale plus plus dur sur des
choses comme ça parce que
on peut le faire dans d'autres
circoncire constance donc on peut le
faire aussi dans le dans le cas dans
leur assise c'est surtout ça dans le
sport ou dans le football on peut je
pense qu'on peut changer tout ça on
parlait ya quelques instants du rapport
justement avec les supporters
avec la france au site un lien qui est
particulier parce que tu as vécu pendant
16 ans en france près de 12 ans à
l'étranger comment comment tu vis un peu
cette distance est ce que ça te manque
parfois
c'est vrai quoi des fois il ya des
moments où j'aimerais bien être est en
france
[Applaudissements]
et
je me dis aussi ça fait tellement
longtemps que je suis je suis à
l'étranger aussi donc j'ai des périodes
où on la jette des envies de de france
des fois j'ai des périodes où j'ai des
envies de l'étranger coup